thousands of things i mean they're going
through it and i give great credit
to the new york post the new york post
for what they did the new york post
i don't know how many of you read the
new york post but it's the oldest paper
in the united states i think it's like
the fifth largest paper
it really is you know you talk about
mainstream media they went out
and they did what these people should
have been doing these people do nothing
[Music]
but i said it very timidly and now i say
it
joe biden is a corrupt politician and he
has been
for a long time and the biden family
is a criminal enterprise and you know it
and so do i in fact
they sort of make crooked hillary
clinton look like
amateur hour you think about it
yet all of this is being covered up by
the media
and big tech you saw that you see that
you put a story out from the new york
post and they
shut down a site how about kaylee
her site got shut down because she put
out a story from the new york post
this is what's going on so they talk
about freedom of speech and freedom of
the press
there's no freedom of the press
but watch what we do but the biggest
thing we can do
november 3rd that's the biggest thing we
can do
[Applause]
because i'm not just running in spidey
we're not just running against joe biden
we're running against the left wing
media
and we're running against big tech
and they all said and i've heard this
that i kept hearing about the power of
big tech the power
and they were against us as you know
four years ago
but i won i said how can they be
powerful i won i never did this before
and i won how the hell are they powerful
but now they've gone totally crazy
they've done things now that they
wouldn't even do and they got caught
and there's great anger in congress in
the senate
there's great anger because what they're
doing is really bad
you know we gave them section 230 it's
protection it protects them from
everything it seals them
so once you do that the government is
giving them something that no other
industry has
so they no longer can say oh freedom of
speech that's a freedom of speech
they've been given protection and
they've abused that protection
and a lot of people are looking now at
big bad
tech but i did say it i said so they're
so powerful how did we win well we won
for a lot of reasons
by the way was that the greatest evening
was that the greatest
we're going to have an even bigger
evening and an
even better evening on november 3rd
despite the fact that they're trying to
get forever to count the balance you
know the
the balance right the fake balance
they're doing everything in their power
to protect
their chosen candidate sleepy joe and he
is a sleepy guy
i watched last night did anybody watch
listen you watched both of them bro
yeah but i watch i just want to see like
how's he doing
not well and remember this they have
nothing but to stand he's just a vehicle
let's not kid ourselves joe is shot okay
he's shot he is a vehicle and he's got
his vice president
who is further left than crazy burning
okay
kamala kamala
nobody treated nobody treated joe biden
worse than kamla during the debates
right
now she got beat up by other people she
got beat up badly
so badly that her polls dropped and she
went out very angry
and then he picked her i said this could
be a very good thing and then mike pence
did a great job the other night didn't
you
[Applause]
so i have nothing but disdain for
what these people have done and they
have nothing but disdain for your values
and you know that
they flood your communities with
criminal aliens drugs crime
while living behind gated compounds they
oppose school choice while sending their
families to the best private schools
they demonize the police while hiring
private security by the way take a look
at the way joe biden lives you know he's
been in congress i guess for almost
50 years i say 47 but the 47 is getting
a little old now right
almost 50 years and he's got houses
and he lives beautifully you know it's
okay if you work and you get out of
beautiful
but this guy's been a politician a
little strange isn't it huh
little strange they say he lives very
well they attack
the second amendment while employing
armed guards they come against you with
the guns they want to take your guns
away you know
if i'm not here i'm the only thing
standing between you and your second
amendment that i can tell you
[Applause]
they support crippling lockdowns while
their jobs
remain totally exempt from being locked
down
how about your governor in michigan she
has that place locked down we just won
the court case though
no the courts just ruled it
unconstitutional what she's doing
the only one that was allowed to enjoy
himself happened to be her husband
right he was going to go boating and her
good time while everyone else was locked
down
somebody caught him who the hell caught
him that was a great thing
you know and then we uh we caught some
people
doing whatever we'll find out what that
was all about
and then she said it was my fault it was
my people that caught them
it was trump's fault it's always trump's
fault can it ever be like
rick gates's fault i mean
so is trump's fault rick by the way how
did the governor do did he get up and
make a great
good governor good guy too right over
here a lot of good people here
it's time we send a message to these
shameless wealthy liberal hypocrites in
washington dc
and silicon valley do you see that
silicon valley
and these guys are 99
behind the democrats okay what's that
all about
what's that all about the 99
not even 90 i'd like to say 90 right 99
well one of the reasons i don't call
them and i don't need their money and i
don't want their money you know that
helps
it really helps let me tell you if i
call them say do me a favor send money
every one of them would send money i
don't like making those calls
because when you make those calls it's
hard to say no
just on a human basis it's very hard to
say no they call and they ask for a
little thing like
how to make an extra five billion
dollars
i don't make those calls you know you
read where they have a lot of money
flowing in this because everyone's
calling everybody we're going to win and
when we win
this is this and this is that's why they
raise money i could raise much more
money president
every call i make every single guy even
if they hated me
they'd all contribute but rick you
understand it i don't want to make those
goals
i don't want to make those calls right
huh
yeah i know where is rick he's here
where is rick where is rick oh you're
there
good so i just want to thank everybody
and we do have some special people
uh matt stand up come here i want to
just tell something
this guy matt gates
so matt matt's been another one of our
stars we're going to introduce some of
our congressmen and
women later but he's done some
special job how are we doing in florida
man
[Applause]
so you know the polls came out today and
they're very good
they don't report them they don't report
them they do report them that they were
bad
but we're not going to have any bad
we're going to have a big day make sure
you work very hard matt and i'll see you
in a second
on election day you can send a message
that the fake news media and the big
tech
sensors because that's what they are the
big senses
and we're going to send them back we're
going to clean out the washington swamp
i never knew it was this deep
but we're cleaning out the washington
swamp
we're going to show them the american
people are in charge
by delivering joe biden sleepy joe a
thundering defeat
like they haven't seen before
like they haven't seen before
if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician it's because i'm
not a politician
sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
and if i don't always play by the rules
of the washington establishment it's
because
i was elected to fight for you harder
than anyone
has ever fought before
this is the most important election in
the history of our country
and you know i used to say it all the
time i'd say well this is important but
the last
and i'm sort of like debating which is
more important
which is more important rick grinnell
tell me which is more important rick
rick grinnell by the way has done a
great job
you know who he is you know what a great
job he's done
he's coming with us i'll tell you that
but
nobody's done the job that we've done
nobody's done the job that we've done
and we've done it with all that
opposition
biden has made a corrupt bargain
exchange for his
party's nomination and he shouldn't have
the nomination
i said this before pocahontas
elizabeth warren should have gracefully
she was defeated she shouldn't have
stayed super tuesday
if she didn't stay for if she would have
left she didn't even have to endorse
anybody if she would have left crazy
bernie
100 would have gotten because he would
have gotten most of her votes
he only needed a few it was really
amazing
and he would have had this guy is the
greatest loser of all time there's no
better loser he just
he's so nice about it it happened to him
twice now right
so she said biden got it so we have a
little bigger base but he's got a base
with
zero enthusiasm zero the only
enthusiasm they have is to beat us and
you know what
it's called negative enthusiasm
typically it never wins we'll find out
it better not win
okay it better not win matt
biden has handed control to the
socialist marxists and far left lunatics
if he wins the radical left will be
running this country
and they're addicted to power and god
help us
if they ever get it because we will
never have the same country again we
never will
we never will you know i used to talk
about venezuela well that is an
amazing amount of people back there
that's an amazing amount of people
turn the camera can you show the group
of people that is unbelievable
that goes back a long way
that's unbelievable thank you
that's fantastic that's fantastic thank
you very much i wish we had
the cameras pushed back further i wish
the cameras were in the back
thank you thank you very much
why don't you drive him crazy just say
12 more years right
[Applause]
they want to punish the middle class
expand
every last trace of traditional values
and replace
the american dream with the socialist
nightmare
that's what it's going to be you take a
look at what's happened with some of
these countries and look at venezuela
18 years ago 17 years ago as one of the
richest countries incredible tremendous
wealth
tremendous natural resources now they
don't have water
they don't have food they don't have
medicine we get them whatever we can
but we're working hard watch what
happens with venezuela watch what
happens with cuba
watch what happens with plenty of places
that are in trouble
because we have to do that we have to
take care of people but look at what's
happened to venezuela
and don't kid yourself i used to say
well that could never happen when you
look at the ideology that we're talking
about now
it's the exact same ideology
it's the exact same ideology
but it's never gonna happen to us
because we're gonna have a big
big victory over the next 18 days
they want to turn america
into a communist country or a socialist
country
you know it didn't used to be i'd use
the word communist but now we talk about
our country will never be a socialist
nation
and now we have to say a socialist or a
communist nation because that's the next
step
we're not going to let it happen and
ruin the lives of hispanic americans and
all americans
we're not letting it happen we're going
to have a big victory
and that'll be the end of it because you
know what one more defeat and they're
going to accept it
you know i talk about unity somebody
asked me a question recently about unity
when do you think the country will come
together
it was coming together i was getting
calls
from politicians that nobody would have
thought on the other side
and they were saying i think it's time i
think it's time we had the greatest
employment numbers in history
we had the greatest we're up to 160
million people
we had the greatest numbers hispanic
americans
african-american asian-american
women we had the greatest
numbers young people with a diploma from
high school without a high school
diploma
with a phd from mit every single group
was having the best numbers we had the
greatest
economic recovery we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world and
then we got hit by the plague from china
but i'll tell you and then we saved
millions of lives
and we're rebuilding at a level that
nobody can even believe
but we were coming together and i told
the person i said the thing that's going
to bring our country together is success
and it was happening and until that
artificial horrible situation
came in it was happening it was
happening like never before
and had that not happened you would have
seen great unity and by the way
the last administration had no unity
look at st
louis look at henderson look at ferguson
look at all of the different look at
oakland
look at baltimore look at the things
that were happening people forget
it was a mess it was a total mess
and then you look at h1n1 that biden
always calls
n1h when i said no joe don't do it joe
he always you can't do it he can't do it
did you see last night he had to take
out the piece of paper
200 million it's not that big a deal 200
let's see
uh i'm not allowed to take out paper
right am i allowed to take out and start
reading up to you
pretty amazing huh pretty amazing he
rips out that paper you know why he does
that because it's not working quite too
well
joe biden and the democrat socialists
will kill your jobs dismantle your
police departments
dissolve your borders by the way our
border now is the strongest it's ever
been 400 miles of water
[Applause]
and mexico is paying for the wall
violence they like to say mexico is that
you know
we get the wall we're up to almost 400
million it's almost complete
it'll be complete versus and really
that's why we have such good numbers now
the wall
you know they used to say we don't want
a wall we want drones oh that's great
you can watch people pour into our
country
right but we got the wall done and i'll
tell you and matt
and these guys they really helped a lot
they were warriors
they helped a lot that was not easy that
was not easy
and ron that's right we forgot ron was a
congressman you know he came to me said
sir i'd like to run for governor
i said well i could you know understand
that but you got a long way to go
i said no i'd like your endorsement if
we have your endorsement i said look ron
let's think about it anyway
you know he's a great guy harvard yale
smart
i said all right ron i'm going to
endorse you who the hell knows what's
going to happen
bones i pressed it he went from 3 to 71
in one day
and then he uh he had an impossible
person to beat you know this guy how's
he doing by the way
how's his opponent doing
he was going to be the future of the
democrat party his opponent
i don't think he's doing too well right
no i'm not doing that watch they'll
resurrect him
the fake news will say it's incredible
what's happened he's wonderful
ah if you were republican they wouldn't
be doing it but that's okay
but ron's been a great governor it was
an honor to be with him and endorse him
he's done a fantastic
the only one better is this great first
lady i like her even better than that
but they'll release criminal aliens
raise your taxes
confiscate your guns a hundred percent
destroy your suburbs they talk about
suburban women do they like donald trump
yeah they like donald trump you know why
because they want safety and security
right they want safety and security
and they don't want low-income housing
built next to their beautiful suburban
dream
now we got rid of it you know they had a
regulation all the women standing up
over there they had a regulation that
destroyed would have destroyed
our suburbs it would have destroyed our
american dream
and they came to me ben carson a lot of
good people they said sir it's very
tough to terminate it but
why don't we just amend it i said i
don't want to amend it what does it mean
it mean
make it a little bit better for us or a
little bit
i said i don't want it amended i wanted
i want that regulation terminated
and they terminated the regulation and
nobody can believe it
and they want to drive god from the
public square
to defend our constitution from this
madness
i proudly nominated judge
amy coney barrett to the united states
supreme court
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no don't worry we'll fill that scene
she's done fantastically well people
can't even believe it what a
breath of fresh air right isn't it nice
she's fantastic
you know what got me her professor one
of her professors long time professor
very highly respected all over the legal
world
had many many many years of students he
said the single
greatest student he's ever had was amy
and that was pretty good you know that
meant something to me right
that meant something to me it is nice
you know you're not allowed to
discriminate
i do like smart people on the supreme
court
now biden wants many people on the
supreme court he doesn't want to say he
said i'll tell you after the election
what they want to do to the court will
be a disaster and by the way you know i
put out a list of
people it's probably one of the reasons
i got elected but now we increased it by
20 great
people that believe in a thing called
the constitution of the united states
but i put out a list so that when we
choose i said i will only take somebody
from that list
and they're incredible scholars and
greater what they do
i said biden has to do that not just
about packing is he going to pack
got to know who is he going to appoint
because you know
the aocs of the world aoc plus three
the arcs of the world
omar omar i think we're going to win you
know what i think we're going to win
minnesota because of omar
[Music]
think of it she hates our country she
hates our country
she comes from a place that doesn't even
have a government and then she comes
here
she tells us how to run our country and
she hates our country
and we're going to win minnesota first
time since 1972.
you imagine hasn't been won by a
republican but we're doing very well
there thank you very much
omar ilhan ilhan omar
thank you very much she's a real she's a
wonderful girl
she's a wonderful person now we got
people it's not even thinkable you know
it used to be that
congress they loved israel today it's
almost like
the opposite it's crazy what they've
done to israel is incredible not the
senate
in all fairness but if you look at the
house with pelosi and these people
it's like they hate israel and they
believe
in omar who came in here married a
brother or something and came in
illegally
come on come on justice let's go justice
department of justice democrats will
pack the court
with radical left judges who will shred
our second amendment
empower violent mobs and protect
terrorists
and criminals you know that biden's
agenda would be
a catastrophe for florida seniors
do we have any seniors in the room no
i'm not a senior okay
i'm not a senior yes i am
especially for everyone from i love the
place the villages
i love them i love the villagers they
fight for us i read stories every day
they're out there they're driving those
beautiful golf carts the nicest golf
carts ever made they've got golf carts
that are better than you call
we love the villages and we're with them
all the way too
they've got spirit they've got heart for
years biden tried to cut your social
security you know that and your medicare
now biden's pledging mass amnesty and
free health care for illegal look he's
got the
illegal immigrants coming in and we all
have heart and we all want to take care
of everybody
but when you say you can have free
health care you can have free education
you can have free
millions of people are going to flood
our country we're not going to have a
country left
so you just can't do it all it is is a
magnet
please come in so we're sorry but uh
we will decimate medicare and destroy
your social security and destroy your
country
while i'm president no one will touch
your medicare or your social security
to reduce the price of prescription
drugs
as you probably have heard that it's not
pleasant for me
i have taken on a thing called big
pharma
they have unlimited money and in a sense
unlimited power they're the biggest
lobbyist in the world they spend more
money than anybody else
i think by far perhaps the lawyers spend
more money
but big pharma i signed the most favored
nations rule which nobody can believe
because you know last year with the only
administration
in 51 years that brought down the cost
of prescription drugs do you know that
but not much one percent
i'm not proud of that one percent but at
least it's something but
the big deal is other countries are
paying a tiny fraction of what we pay
for the same exact
drug the same pill ten cents versus two
and a half dollars
and we pay by far more than anybody and
it's us
because they view us as suckers so i
said to big pharma you can either do
these things and get rid of the
middlemen
and all of the things that we do you
know i'll bet you hunter biden is a
middleman you know that i'm just
right
[Music]
now i know i don't know you know the
middle man with drugs
the middlemen it's called the middlemen
they never say the middleman or woman
they're not politically correct they
don't care they make so much money these
are the richest people
i don't even know who the hell they are
i'll bet you that hunter biden has a
piece of that action
the middlemen we're getting rid of the
middlemen we're giving the governors the
right
and your governor wanted it the first
one to go to canada
where the same exact drug costs 50
they're gonna buy in florida until the
favored nations kicks in which will be
even better
they're going to buy drugs from
prescription drugs from canada
at 50 off and you're going to get the
benefit think of that because we have a
long-time
system that's corrupt like so many other
things and uh hard to break so we're
breaking it by letting them go and buy
and we have various states but florida
is going to be one of them you're going
to go you're going to buy them for much
less
but ultimately that'll stop because the
greatest is favorite nation
so you will have and you will be paying
the lowest
price we're going to match the lowest
price anywhere
in the world you're the biggest buyer
and that's what it's going to be
plus we capped insulin costs for
medicare plans at less than 35
a month it was much much higher many
times higher my people did a great job
in that you know insulin was driving
people out of business and people were
dying
because they couldn't afford it they
couldn't do it and every senior
on medicare will soon be receiving two
hundred dollars to help with the cost of
your
medicines and we got that approved too
we got a lot
nobody has done what i've done for
seniors that i can tell you we have a
lot of great plans too
biden had 47 years to do what i did
but he's owned by the special interests
and he's owned by the drug companies
he's never going to do this stuff
he can't do it i don't need their money
i don't want their money i never asked
for their money who the hell knows maybe
they gave me something along the line
sir you received 400 from pfizer
seven years ago but you know what i
couldn't care less
i'm here to do a job and i'm going to
leave and i'm going to hope
hopefully you're going to say i was a
great president but that's going to be
in four years
that'll be in four years
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much under my leadership
we're delivering a safe vaccine and a
rapid recovery
we're doing things with fta they're
giving us approvals in weeks as opposed
to years it's been
incredible if you vote for me prosperity
will surge
normal life that's all we want we want
normal life right
normal we don't want anything we want we
want to be
where we were seven months ago
and next year will be one of the best
and greatest years in the history of our
country that's what's happening
economically and that's going to lead to
others
this election is a choice between a
trump recovery
and a biden depression he gets in
they're gonna
quadruple your taxes they're gonna take
away all of the benefits that i gave you
which turned out to be
a lot you add energy and it's probably
seven or eight thousand dollars
think of that seven or eight thousand
dollars a year did you ever see
yourself with like two dollar gasoline
did you ever see that did you ever see
that happening
how about less than two dollars and at
the same time
we are now energy independent and we
have millions and millions of people
working on energy millions of people
millions of people now we're very proud
of it the uh
you know we are uh independent we don't
have to be in the middle east we don't
have to be we're there to protect israel
we're there to help
others but we don't need it anymore we
used to need it
we don't need it anymore because of what
we've done and and by the way
the fracking this guy he goes around
talking about fracking all the time i
mean think about it
there will be under no circumstances
there will be no fracking then he gets
it
he goes to pennsylvania and i love
pennsylvania
and he says oh wow they have a lot of
jobs here about a million jobs for
acting right
he goes i got a problem so it goes all
right who the hell cares i've been
saying this for a year and a half no
fracking now he gets up
yeah we'll let you frack absolutely we
never said that
and the fake news doesn't ever even ask
the question
no i mean they don't even ask the
question
they don't even ask the question i mean
this guy goes through a thing last night
with stephanopoulos i like george
but he did me two weeks ago he did an
interview with me
and it was nasty right was this last
night that was [ __ ] sleep
everyone's falling asleep why don't they
ask him the fact that why for a year and
a half did he say there's no fracking
and then the day he gets the nomination
he goes into pennsylvania
he learned he knows nothing about
pennsylvania by the way he
you know he likes to say i was born in
pennsylvania that's it and then they
left
maybe they didn't like it they didn't
like it
i love you too look at her she's
thank you thank you very much it's very
nice thank you
but no but why don't they ask him that
like for a year and a half
there will be no fracking how about this
i said oh the election's over
who they said a lot of these people on
the stage the democrats they said
who is going to pay for
illegal immigrants health care who
agrees to pay they all raise their hand
you saw that right
i said that's beautiful but joe's hand
hasn't but i saw his shoulder was moving
right right because he knew you know his
mind isn't so good so he knows there's
something bad going on
he's been doing this for 47 years so he
says like
i got a problem i have no idea what the
question means but
they're all racing so he's like this and
then finally he goes this and i said i
just won the election that's great
but then they deny it then they go and
they didn't i've never seen anything
whether it's that or the fracking or
other things they just deny it like it
didn't exist
and they get a free pass from our
corrupt media
it's a corrupt media i used to say
fake i used to think that was one of the
greatest things that came up fake news
right that was me
but i said you know but now i i have to
go a step further it's
fake and it's corrupt and a lot of times
i leave the fake off because
you know corrupt is the stage worse and
many
and i'll tell you and this is true it's
a single it's
just about it causes the problems it's
the enemy of the people our media
is the enemy of the people it's
very very dangerous what they do and
you've never seen it more than the last
week between the big tech
and they're working on section 230. you
watch what's going to happen
but you've never seen a more egregious
case than what's been happening over the
last three or four years
i will deliver optimism opportunity and
hope
speaking of hope hope hicks is here
where's hope hicks
where's hope
the great hope hicks you know she was
tested positive but
she's okay where's hope we want hope
right
we want hope i used to say we want hope
and all these crazy people said yeah we
want
where's hope where's hope come here
come here come here hope
come on she's shy but not that shy
hope we want hope
see
[Music]
we can share a microphone now
thank you all so much and thank you
president trump
i have stage fright so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah she's great
so she tested positive and she got
better so fast it was like
that's called being young strong right
young and strong but she's been
fantastic thank you hope we're proud of
your hope
so biden will deliver pessimism poverty
and decline and that's what he's gonna
look you know what drives me when i see
he's always criticized saying oh
i didn't act fast enough with china but
for two months after i did it he said
i was what xenophobic i said what does
that mean i was xenophobic
what does it mean joe tell me exactly
please give me a definition he said
i don't know that's what they told me to
say but you know
two months later he's saying i shouldn't
have done it right
but now his whole line is i didn't act
fast enough i did it in january he's
talking about it in
february and beyond late february beyond
that i shouldn't have done it then i did
europe too very early i saw
big infections in spain and italy
i did europe nobody even talks about it
so we did with
over 200 000 people but remember this we
were expected to lose 2.2 million people
and maybe more than that
and our people whether it's vice
president pence or
all of these people that work so hard on
the task force they've done an
incredible job they've done an
incredible job
and when you look at our numbers and
when you look at the surge that's taking
place right now and we're going down
and europe is going way up they used to
love to compare us but we compared very
favorably
but now we're making ventilators for
europe and the rest of the world we're
doing things that nobody thought was
even possible
so i just want to thank all of the
people that worked so hard on that
that's been an amazing amazing
experience
but a guy like sleepy joe biden would
terminate our recovery
delay the vaccine prolong the pandemic
and annihilate florida's incredible
economy your economy
is starting to boom with a draconian
unscientific lockdown and you know what
happens with the lockdowns right you
know what happened to people
when they're in the lockdowns biden's
plan will crush
america my plan will crush the virus
and america will be in a position very
soon like it was never
in before that's what's happening
[Music]
this week even the failing new york
times
had no choice but to quote and they put
a statement
probably the writer of the article has
been fired since it's been three days
but they said experts are excuses quote
experts are saying with
genuine confidence new york times that
the pandemic in the united states
will be over far sooner than anybody
expected isn't that nice
can't believe it i heard that i said
give it to me again let me hear that
again because i don't believe
it our early and aggressive action saved
as many as two million but maybe much
more as we said
maybe much more than that we pioneered
life-saving therapies
well here i am i mean you know
i don't know what the hell they gave me
but i'll take some more of it right now
because i thought
no i had something regeneron great
really you know
the antibody things and eli lilly also
makes something very similar and
we're having a lot of it produced right
now and we're going to be delivering it
and it's going to be something but you
know our
fatality rate 85 think of it
we have it reduced 80 to 85 percent all
the way down so this is what
we've done is incredible we understand
what's going on we understand that
99.9 for young people
like baron baron gets he's
i said how you feeling not good how are
you feeling two hours later i'm feeling
great dad that's you know
whether we like it or not they have a
little better immune system than we do
right you know
we don't like to admit it let's never
admit it but that's the way it is
no baron's great our first lady is great
[Music]
people love our frustration they love
our first lady
now the abuse that she takes she's a
fantastic woman she loves you she says
love
but they love our first lady
i love her
and they love our family how about
ivanka do we love ivanka
[Applause]
and don and eric and tiffany they all
and they gave up a lot you know you
don't read that
i lost hundreds of millions billions of
dollars through this you know this cost
me billions right
i don't take the salary it's 400 450 000
i don't do this but if an arab gentleman
happens to stay one night in one of my
hotels
for 642.13
headlines trump is ripping off the sun
right these people are bad
billions of dollars i lost by doing this
and you know what the greatest
investment i ever made because it's an
investment in our country
it's an investment in our country
thank you the greatest thing i've ever
done
and we are doing things that nobody else
would have been able to do and i'm only
doing it because of you
you know when you think we're doing it
together but
we are the difference between having a
great country and our country's going to
be at a level in two years three years
we need a little time to seed
some of the things we've done we still
have more regulation cutting to do we've
cut more than
any other administration in history by
far
but we still have more you know it used
to take 18
17 20 21 it would take years and years
21 years to get a highway approved and
then usually it didn't get approved
and it would cost hundreds of times more
than anticipated
we have that down now to two years and
probably one
i mean things like that and it may get
rejected for environmental or safety
reasons that's
okay but it's going to go quickly
there's no reason
you've seen the charts i put them up all
the process the process that you had to
go through
to get a simple thing done and now we're
building refineries we're building
incredible
things things that we're not if somebody
applied for a refinery in the old days
people would laugh at them they say you
never get that approved
if you go to louisiana you take a look
in texas you take a look at what they're
doing in terms of refineries
right it's incredible the things we're
doing are incredible
and that's all because of us so this is
the greatest thing i've ever done
because
nobody would be able to do what we
as a group have been able to do for our
customers
[Music]
so i'm working to make the antibody
treatment that i received available
to anybody that needs it free because it
wasn't your fault
it wasn't your fault and i view it i
mean they call it a therapeutic i view
it as a cure
because i didn't feel too good i didn't
have a temperature in a lot of years
all of a sudden sure you got a little
temperature going though that's great
and i woke up and i'm telling you uh
literally the following day i
i couldn't get and walter reed hospital
one of the great walter e
military hospital in the world
but i want to thank johns hopkins too
but one thing when you're president and
you're not feeling too good
you're laying in bed there's about 14
doctors surrounding you where are you
from
everyone's like a who's who but uh no
what they did is incredible and we're
making that available to everybody that
needs it we've signed i've signed an
emergency declaration we're telling
everyone to get it approved
and we want to thank dr hahn at the fda
they're working very very hard to get it
approved very quickly
we're trying to get things approved in a
matter of weeks it used to take years
it used to take years that includes
other drugs for other things where
you'd have many many years and a person
is terminally ill
and they go to asia or they go home if
they had no money they'd have no choice
they'd go home
and they'd die but we have incredible
drugs but it would take another four or
five
six years it would take 10 years we've
cut that number down in half maybe even
more than half
for other drugs cancer drugs etc but we
have
a thing called right to try i talk about
it every once in a while
i'm so proud of it it has had such an
incredible impact right to try it's a
great name to me
and it's somebody's terminally ill and
we have a drug that looks really
promising
and they're not allowed to use it
because they're afraid it's going to
make the person sick i said the person
is going to die
but not that easy because you had the
drug companies didn't want to take the
liability yet the country didn't want to
take the liability
the drug companies as an example they
didn't want to have it on their records
because somebody's that sick
and it looks bad on their records the
person didn't make it
so i said what we'll do is we'll set up
a different sheet we'll set up a
different sheet and maybe we won't even
count it if somebody is so sick
and then of course you had the insurance
companies they hated the idea
and we got them in a room and we had
somebody we had a very strong document
that there will be no liability to the
country and you have an absolute right
to try so somebody's terminally ill
you have no idea how many people have
been saved
by doing this some incredible stories so
i mean that's one of many many things
that's one of many many things people
don't even talk about it but it's been
you know it's been just an incredible
privilege
through operation warp speed we will
have 100 million vaccine doses before
the end of this year
the vaccine will end the pandemic once
and for all and frankly i'll say it and
they'll hate this
well they actually love it even without
the vaccine the pandemic's going to end
it's going to run its course it's going
to end they go crazy he said without the
vaccine watch
it'll be a headline tomorrow these
people are crazy
now it's running its course we're
rounding the turn you see the numbers
we're rounding the turn and
you know this state three months ago you
know what happened three months ago we
had a surge here we had a surge in texas
we had a surge in arizona great governor
great governor of texas
great governor in arizona great people
and you have a great governor here we
had surges
and they went up and they went down and
now you're at your lowest numbers
and you're open and you didn't close and
you're it's just amazing right
so we're joined today by one of the
greatest governors
in our country and i know a lot of good
ones and i can tell you there's some
really bad ones too
but this is a great one governor ron
desantis
thank you ron i heard your speech was
great ron
i heard you did a great job but he's
done a great job and he's been my friend
hey ron are we going to win the state
please
you know if we don't win it i'm blaming
the governor i'll fire him somehow i'm
going to fire
i will find a way anyway thank you
and members of congress and friends of
mine and warriors
matt gates who we said hello to matt
great guy great guy is this your area a
little bit
no no not too much but they know him
everybody knows
now he's a warrior he's a fighter also
neil
dunn where's deal neil thank you very
much
i like your tie now i like your i like
you shooting your time
that's great and another man who knows
so much about the military i'll call him
a lot
mike waltz
[Music]
he knows so much about the military
good the both of them well both of them
good great job thank you great to have
you phil congressional candidate
kat kamik she's fantastic
aren't you like in a trump 45 or
something tell me what how many points
up
how much well that's pretty good that's
a good trump district i'll tell you
that's going to be there she's going to
win it that's great job
and a woman who was in charge of
michigan you all know her she was in
charge of michigan michigan hadn't been
won by a republican in
decades and decades she was horrendous
to me she kept calling me please sir one
more speech just come to michigan you're
gonna win at us
all right finally toward the end four
years ago i said you know what
that's it okay i'm leaving that's it i'm
not coming back
that's okay so you don't have to we're
going to win it i get a call the
following day so you have to come back
for one voicemail
and i did it and we won the great state
of michigan and she was in charge
head of the republican party now
chairwoman
ronna mcdaniel
[Applause]
oh she's great she doesn't stop how are
we doing in michigan by the way
i heard that yeah paul came out we're up
one in michigan we're doing well i mean
they should be we should be up 30 in
michigan
we brought many car plants you know they
hadn't had a plan for 40 years
and we have many of them being built in
michigan so we're going to do great in
michigan
today we're also praying for all of the
families on the florida panhandle i love
that panhandle
i don't know what it is i know it's a
little away from here but i'm gonna say
it anyway hurricane sally
the panhandle you know we came and we
were doing really well in florida
and then the panhandle hadn't been
counted yet right matt
and we went out and they said trump has
just won florida so wait a minute they
haven't even
gotten through it they said no the
panhandle was like 94
or something they said if trump is even
coming into the panhandle there's nobody
going to beat trump
and we want it pretty easily i'll tell
you but the panhandle so we're with the
panhandle 100
great people last month i approved a
major disaster
declaration for the state of florida and
i'll be with you all the way
and we're doing some rebuilding you got
hit with a lot of storms and a lot of
hurricanes and we're with you all the
way
and you know when ron calls up he's
always calling me oh
sir we need more money for this
hurricane that hurricane
we need more money for lake okeechobee
you don't care about lake okeechobee
lake okeechobee is pretty far away but
uh he wants more but that's what a
governor should be doing right when you
think about it
i can get angry at him i can say that's
enough but he's uh
he's somebody that wants it and you're
two senators by the way
marco and rick they're doing a great job
and they're right now in washington
fighting for our
new supreme court justice okay marco
and rick great people they're great
people
under my administration we built the
greatest economy in the history of the
world
and now we are doing it again you know
what it's called make america great
again again
see all those hats make america great
make america great again again
but i don't want to do it a third time
okay just let's
but we're doing it really nicely it's
coming along at a level that nobody can
believe
but these numbers are amazing in my
first three years
family income increased by 6 thousand
dollars three years three years more
than five
times the gains in all eight years
under the sleepy joe slash obama
administration oh i got an emergency
call today
they say sir i'm sorry to tell you
president obama is going to start
campaigning for sleepy jail
i said so what's the problem with that
and they said well
you know he's going to start i said well
you know he campaigned harder than
hillary last time so why do we care
the other thing he refused to endorse
joe he knows what's going on up here
with joe
and obama refused to endorse him and
even after joe had won he didn't want to
and then finally like a long time later
he finally came out and indoors
but they called me they said you know
obama's going to start campaigning
i said is that good or bad because i
think it's a good thing
because you know they did a lousy job
and i wouldn't be
president of the united states if they
did a good job i wouldn't be
i probably wouldn't have run and if i
did i probably
wouldn't have won you know so it's one
of those things they did a lousy job and
that's why i'm your president
african-american income
through nine times more think of that
african-american these are numbers that
larry kudlow given to me right from the
book the great larry kudlow
african-american income
think of this grew nine times
more than it did under biden and obama
right that's a big number
african-american unemployment hispanic
american
unemployment and asian american
unemployment
all reached record levels like levels
that nobody sees
it is amazing when biden sits and he
criticizes you and then i say wait a
minute
it's not like he left 25 years ago he
left
four years ago yes and i say you know
he's always criticizing and he's not
criticized he's got guys that write they
write pretty well too by the way
he has no idea what he's reading but
he's very critical
and and you think he's been doing this
stuff for 47 years
why didn't he do it before why didn't he
do it before
we lifted 6.6 million americans out of
poverty
since the china virus we have created a
record in the history of our country
11.4 million jobs over just a short
period of months
we've already cut the unemployment rate
in half and we're now down to 7.8 and
i'll tell you what i never thought i'd
be happy with 7.8 i told you
but when i hear 42 38 it's going to go
to a number like nobody in history
i said we can't let this happen and we
did a hell of a job under biden it took
30 months
to recover more than half of the jobs
lost in the crisis
we did it instead of 30 months we did it
in five months
think of that
jobs have been recovering 23
times faster than the obama
recovery which was by the way the worst
recovery
slowest recovery in the history of our
country
now they only go back till 1929 so you
know i don't want to have them say
there was something that happened in
1851 but i don't think
they go back to i think 29 all right
long time but it's the slowest the worst
recovery we've stopped
businesses from leaving and factories
are pouring back into our country
we've spent the last four years
reversing the damage
joe biden inflicted over the last 47
years on nafta
we got rid of nafta right did i tell you
where you're gonna everyone said you
can't do it
you know why you couldn't do it they
said you couldn't you know why because
it was so good for mexico
and because it was so good for canada
they said you'll never pull it off
they have a lot of power in our country
those two countries i got rid of nafta
and now we have the usmca which is just
kicking in
and the other two countries we like them
both very much but they're not thrilled
tpp we wouldn't allow it to happen that
would have destroyed your automobile
businesses
right and china's entry
into the world trade organization joe
biden approved that one
the single worst deal we've ever made
because china was flatlining until that
happened
and then they became like a rocket ship
and they are considered you know
a developing nation and i said if
they're a developing nation then we're a
developing nation too because as a
developing nation
you get tremendous bonuses and it's you
get it's ridiculous
no more and by the way we just won a
lawsuit seven and a half billion dollars
we haven't won
[Music]
they're treating us with respect but
we'll find out about the world trade and
we took ourselves out of the world
health organization is that okay
we took ourselves out of the world
health organization
because frankly uh you know we put up
500 million a year
so we have 325 million people we put up
500 million if world health okay it's
not the biggest thing
but it's a lot we did 500 million china
1.4 billion people they put up 39
million a year
other than that it's a very fair deal
okay this is the kind of stuff that we i
see the stuff that
i could i could tell you a hundred
different stories it's so
stupid and so unfair so we took
ourselves out they're dying to have us
back in i could go back in for about
three dollars a year
he screams don't go back that's the
problem if i went back for
a half a million dollars right i'd be
criticized the democrats would say what
a terrible thing to do
it's incredible deal after i could tell
you hundreds of
stories but we just take care of it all
and we do it really well
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations
fighting foreign wars and defending
foreign borders
but now we are finally protecting our
nation rebuilding our cities
and we are bringing our jobs our
factories
and our troops back home to the usa
they're coming back
and we've achieved energy independence
and we've done it while protecting
our pristine environment you know right
now
we have the best numbers from an
environmental standpoint that we've ever
had all this talk you know paris accord
which was a total rip-off of our country
but all of this talk we have the best
numbers that we've had ever now ever i
always have to preface it because these
people
ever meaning let's say over the last 50
years because you know once you get back
too far we had no people
right you know i could say the best in
over 200 years well you know 200 years
ago i wouldn't say we had too many
factories i recently signed an order
placing a moratorium
on offshore drilling off the coast of
georgia north carolina
south carolina and a place known as
florida are you okay with that
are you okay with that you know the one
that wanted it more than anybody else
was florida
florida didn't want to see sludge coming
onto their beaches so you're not going
to have it so i just signed that up
and so you're all protected and matt
worked very hard on it
he worked very very hard on it and so
did your other
great people here today and your
governor wanted it very badly so we got
it done we invested 2.5
trillion dollars in the united states
military
we launched the first new branch of the
u.s
armed forces in 75 years it's called
the space force
[Applause]
[Music]
i brought back nasa which is now the
number one space center by far in the
world it was a closed-up mess
and we passed va choice and va
accountability
and we have now a 91
approval with our vets never had
anything even close
we beat down isis took 100
of the isis caliphate in syria
you saw that and iraq and when i came in
it was a mess it was all over the place
and we did it we have generals that are
so
incredible we the real generals i'm
talking not the paper generals you have
some of them too
we have some highly rated highly
overrated generals and we have some
great ones but these guys were
unbelievable we took a hundred percent
remember i said all right we're coming
home we got 99
they said no the paper they said
we want a hundred percent i said we're
at 99 i want to bring them home no we
want to hunt so i stayed for another
couple of weeks
and we took 100 and we killed the leader
of isis who's killed so many people al
baghdad
[Applause]
right
and we took out the world's number one
terrorist and the number one
mass murderer probably well for a long
time
killed many american troops killed many
troops killed many people
kasim sulaimani is dead
he's dead
one of the biggest things ever to happen
in the middle east people couldn't even
believe it
and i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous
150 billion dollars 1.8 billion in cash
disastrous iran nuclear deal and you
know what
when we win when we win the first call
i'm going to get
and i'm not doing this as anything and
i'm not trying to taunt anybody
but because it makes sense their economy
has gone to hell with our sanctions and
everything i've done
when we win the first call i'm going to
get is a call from iran let's make a
deal
and i'm going to get calls from other
countries they all want to make a deal i
said let's see you know because their
dream is that
sleepy joe wins because if sleepy joe
wins
china will own the united states if
sleepy joe wins
iran will make another crazy deal where
we pay him a fortune for nothing we got
nothing in that deal
that was a john kerry incompetent deal
and the only time he got up instead of
walking away
was to go to a bicycle race remember
that 73 years old
and that's when i pledged i will never
ever enter a bicycle race
and he fell and he broke his leg at his
shoulder or something
but at least it forced him away from the
table i thought maybe we got lucky
i kept my promise recognized the true
capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
[Applause]
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
they've been talking about that for 52
years
they'd fly in fly out 52 years
i got it done in about two hours
and instead of the endless war we are
forging peace in the middle east in fact
i got
three nobel peace prize nominations
[Applause]
only one for the middle east only one
for the middle east
let's see what happens let's see what
happens but you know i tell you because
they don't cover it
when obama got it he didn't he just said
what did i do he had no idea what he did
and they made it a big story when i got
it i did a good job
kosovo serbia you know they were killing
each other for many years killing lots
of people
it was like just they fight for years
and decades and centuries that they just
fight
and we're making these trade deals i
said wait a minute well we're making the
deals let's put these two countries
together let's save a lot of lives
and it was easy because you know we have
all the cards we have the
money we have the trade we we got them
together
we made wonderful deals for our country
but as part of the deal
we got them together economically
together isn't that good right
nobody can believe it but that's the way
you do it
i did more in 47 months than joe biden
did in 47 years
[Applause]
but now the democrats are pushing the
most far-left agenda ever put forward by
a presidential
nominee you know it's an amazing thing
this is the weakest presidential
go ahead say it go ahead
100 year old veteran right here
[Applause]
wow
man he looks beautiful 100 huh
looks better than i do
100 that's great what's your name
well i want to thank you very much and
he does not need
regeneron okay that i can tell you he
looks you look fantastic so sit down and
enjoy it okay
what a beautiful guy 100 you look
beautiful thank you congratulations
that's nice great i'm glad you pointed
it out
the biden plan would destroy social
security destroy protections for
pre-existing conditions you know that
biden vowed to terminate our travel bans
on jihadist regions he wants to get rid
of the travel you know i won the travel
ban right
so that countries that hate us countries
that want to
hurt us they can't send their people
somehow that makes a little sense
105.
that's beautiful wow 105.
wow
105.
so he went through what what how many
two how many wars two wars
well he looks good i'll tell you that's
great congratulations you look beautiful
he's got a better head of hair than i do
i like your hair better than mine look
at that guy
105 and he's got better hair than the
president
good enjoy it thank you very much for
being here we appreciate it 105.
beautiful thank you very much
so they want to surge refugee admissions
by
700 this was agreed to with crazy bernie
opening the floodgates to radical
islamic terrorism we're not doing it
he'll ban school choice which we have to
have so important
they want to end charter schools you
know why because he's controlled by
certain people you know who the people
are and i say it
with hesitation because i have
tremendous respect for teachers okay
tremendous respect i love teachers
and he wants to end your florida
opportunity scholarships
in the second term i will provide school
choice to every parent in america we're
already started
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities
great jobs and a limitless future for
all americans it's very simple
it's really a vote for the american
dream that's what it is like these
two guys 100 and 105 look at him
great going great that's beautiful a lot
of spirit
hey do we have spirit or what
[Applause]
well that's one thing even the fake news
admits our
level of enthusiasm the trump whatever
the hell you want to call us the group
is way is off the charts i believe it's
the highest in the history of elections
but
[Applause]
it's the highest in history and his
level of
enthusiasm is called non-existent
it's non-existent there is no enthusiasm
you go through the communities there's
signs on every trump pence trump pence
trump trump pens
i mean you have to see it it's like
unbelievable you don't see biden stuff
you don't see it
we have the greatest level of enthusiasm
they say
i don't know that they've ever recorded
and by the way one other thing
gallup came out with a poll the other
day you saw it right 56
of the people in a pandemic are better
off now than they were
under the obama advisor
and it's the best number i think they
said ever recorded
and we're in a pandemic it's not
anybody's fault but we're in a pandemic
56 there's another one that's even more
interesting
62 of the people pole this was gallop i
think
62 of the people polled right
said they're lying if that's the case
we're gonna have the greatest landslide
in history
i don't know if it's true i don't know
if i should be honored by it but we'll
take it
i probably shouldn't be talking about it
but we'll take it
no did you see that one 62 percent of it
because they don't want to be bothered
just leave me alone we'll vote for buy
new to health cares but then they go
i can tell you a lot of people vote for
us and you have no idea because they
want low taxes
they want a strong military they want a
lot of things that we're doing over the
next four years
we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will
end our reliance on china once and for
all which we're already doing we will
hire more police
increase penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
thank you
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms your
second amendment
[Applause]
[Music]
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens
and we will keep america out of the
endless horrible ridiculous
foreign wars
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength and that's what we have
we have now the greatest equipment any
country has ever possessed
the greatest in the world all made in
the usa by the way
we've restocked we've rebuilt we have
the greatest fighter jets
missiles rockets ships we have the
greatest military ever
russia china everybody is envious they
know
everybody is envious we have the
hydrosonic missiles that you used to
hear about we didn't have them
because other countries were stealing
our plans from the obama administration
but we now have hydrosonic missiles we
have the greatest
military ever and we did it very very
quickly and i only hope to god you know
our whole
nuclear arsenal has been redone hope to
god
we never have to use it but the fact
that we are so strong
when i came here you heard the story one
of the generals most highly overrated
general i've ever met actually
he said sir we have no ammunition i said
no president you'd ever have to hear
that we have no ammunition
now we have so much ammunition we don't
know what the hell to do with it
all made in the usa we will end surprise
medical billing
require price transparency already
signed and it kicks in on january 1st
and further reduce the cost of
prescription drugs
we will strongly protect medicare and
social security
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions please remember
and we got rid of the individual mandate
from obamacare which was
a disaster and if we can end obamacare
we'll end up with a much
better health care at a much lower cost
with protection for people with
pre-existing conditions
so we'll see how that all works out
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states
we'll be the first nation to land an
astronaut
on mars our space center nasa
by the way is that a beautiful sight
look at that plane
[Music]
i mean i hate to tell you but i have the
exact same plane that hole
that's it true the exact same the exact
same play
except it's a different company that
made the engines i think those are pratt
whitney and i have rolls royce i'm sorry
no i have the exact same plane but that
is one of the most beautiful planes 757
one of the most beautiful planes
in the world that's the smaller version
of air force one you know that see i'm
trying to save a couple of bucks for the
contract
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
school
[Music]
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
[Applause]
and by the way you see what's happening
with all these sports leagues that don't
respect our
country right they're going down the
tubes their ratings are down the nba
the nba's down 70 because you know what
people don't want to hear it they want
to watch sports
they've got enough politics they don't
want to hear it so you know what
it's too bad but that's the way it is
stand proud for our flag
and stand proud for our anthem right
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national model
in god we trust
for years you had a president to
apologize for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
florida right
so get your friends get your family
get your co-workers get everybody even
if you have a boss get the boss and say
boss i'm going to rip you out of your
office we're going to go
and we're going to vote go vote it's the
most important election
in our history this is more important
than four years ago
most important election in our history
early voting starts
on monday so remember and keep your eyes
open when you watch these ballots coming
in
thank you i love you too
go out and vote send in your absentee
ballots if you want to do it that way
but make sure it counts
from tampa to tallahassee from pensacola
to miami
and from jacksonville to right here in
ocala
i love ocala i love this place
i love horses right you like horses
around here right
a lot of friends who live here we
inherit the legacy of
florida patriots who gave their blood
sweat and tears for this beloved nation
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes
who crossed the oceans blazed the trails
settled the continent
tamed the wilderness laid down the
railroads
dug out the panama canal raise up the
giant skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and from here in this beautiful
wonderful
state with that fabulous sun landed
our brave american astronauts on the
face of the moon right
we made america into the single greatest
nation in the history of the world
and the best is yet to come it's coming
fair
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people
that's happening now
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
[Music]
[Applause]
we are one movement one people
one family and one glorious nation under
god
and together with the incredible people
of florida
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we will make america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you very much get out
and vote
[Music]
[Music]
i said
[Music]
mca
you can do whatever you feel
but you've got to
[Music]
to the ymca
[Music]
is
[Music]
i was
someone came up to me
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
now
wow
tell me
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
pirate's mind
[Music]
you must have seen
[Music]
and now she's in me
always with me
[Music]
[Music]
turning
[Music]
is
[Music]
looking on she sings the songs
only you and you can't hear me
when i say softly
[Music]
slowly
on the highway
[Music]
dance
on the highway
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
you must see
now she's in me
always with me
in my head
[Music]
when i say softly
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
you